I'm back from New Zealand I'm now in Los  Angeles I was visiting family down at  the bottom of the world  Psych the world doesn't have a bottom  that's why I picked up one of these an  upside down world map putting North at  the top of a map is purely convention  there's no reason to depict South  America below North America except that  a long time ago people who lived in the  northern half of the world decided to  put themselves at the top and that's  what we today are still used to seeing I  love how completely sensical this whole  map is but yet how different it feels of  course you don't need a physical map  like this to experience the world from  another perspective since the labels on  Google Maps are always right side up  regardless of where you put North you  can make East the top of the map or  whatever you want point is in space no  one can hear you scream and no one knows  what's up